At the top of the course viewer, where
you're watching this video, you'll see a progress bar.
It looks something like this. As you go along,
watching a course, the videos that you have already
watched will turn blue as you pass them. Videos that you're currently
watching are orange. Videos that you haven't watched yet remain shaded
out in gray. You might notice that some videos have dots in them.
These dots indicate the presence of quizzes at the
end of the video. The dot changes from white
to blue after you've completed it. If you skip
the quiz, the dot remains white. This reminds you
to go back and complete the quiz when you
have time. You can go to any video segment
of the course by clicking directly in the progress
bar on the section that you want to visit.
Let's go back to the classroom to the software development course
to demonstrate the progress bar. Notice that when you hover over each
section, you can see the names of the videos. There's also
a drop-down menu, where you can toggle between lessons in the course.